jetzt ist es raus dass seit Tagen
erwartete Interview des usagitators Taka
Carlsen mit Vladimir Putin weder
äußerlich noch inhaltlich gibt es dabei
etwas Neues allerdings fragt die
britische dailymail ob der russische
Diktator an einer Stelle versucht mit
der Hand sein zitterndes Bein zu
beruhigen ansonsten quält Putin den
trumpnahen amerikanischen Journalisten
mit seiner 25 minütigen Version der
russischen Geschichte nach Putins
Darstellung ist Russland in allen
aktuellen Konflikten die verfolgte
Unschuld der westenbauer Russland zum
Schreckgespenst auf Berichte über eine
russische Bedrohung oder gar eine
atomare Auseinandersetzung sein all samt
unwahr und bloß eingebildet um Angst zu
verbreiten später behauptet Putin er
habe US-Präsident Bill Clinton früher
gefragt ob Russland in die NATO
aufgenommen werden könne doch der habe
nein gesagt mit Blick auf den
ukrainekrieg sagt Putin gegen Ende des
Interviews man sei zum Dialog bereit die
Zeit für Gespräche sei gekommen weil der
Westen erkennen müsse dass der Konflikt
für ihn militärisch nicht zu gewinnen
sei